you just have to accept this is what
what drives me but I think that with
comedies especially because I would like
to improvise and I would you know go to
the set have a bunch of different ideas
and then those ideas would you know
create like other ideas and and then the
pressure being like you know this is a
movie I I want I just know I can't have
any regrets I can't walk away feeling
like could have done better I could have
I should have you know trusted myself
and done like this idea you know and
then afterwards and especially when it
works I remember in the beginning like
with American pies and some other
comedies when it works and you're
sitting in a theater and you're hearing
people laugh at it it's like oh it was
worth the stress it was all it was worth
the you know the self-portrait